tiroirs caisses vides coffre fort
arraché portes forcées les campings du
morvan ont commencé la semaine avec
pertes et fracas
on a retrouvé donc la porte de la petite
boutique ouverte avec le cadenas fort
c'est juste à côté et à l'intérieur là
où situer le coffre-fort
donc on peut voir encore les marques de
scellage donc qui ont été enlevés sur la
rive d'en face à à peine quelques
encablures le même scénario
balas pour reprendre le travail mais
serein puisque que de l'argent qui a été
pris on aurait pu nous voler des
ordinateurs des bateaux dans la nuit de
dimanche à lundi ce sont plus d'une
dizaine de lieux d'accueil de touristes
qui ont été visités un dénominateur
commun
seul l'argent a été dérobé nous avons
nous on veut faire un raid en quelque
sorte c'est un raid avec 13 campings
municipaux ou privés qui ont été visés
par des délinquants qui s'attaquait au
coffre-fort ou au tiroir caisse pour le
procédé est assez basique un les gens
viennent dans les campings force les
forçaient les accès et ensuite des robes
et oui tu peux retrouver comme comme
argent l'anc est toujours en cours mais
les recherches s'affine dans un domaine
résidentiel donc avait vacances et des
résidents secondaires et certains ont
repéré une voiture étrange enfin qui
roulait lentement vitres teintées quatre
personnes dedans très tard très tard le
dimanche soit simplement bon ça arrive
je veux dire c'est vrai que c'est cette
voiture qui a été identifié par
différents opérateurs touristiques et
qui a été retrouvée par la gendarmerie
le préjudice estimé s'élève à plus de
10000 euros sans compter les chèques
les gendarmes appellent à la vigilance
en cette période estivale